ก็
สวัสดีครับ 5 สวยครับน้องเรียมไปทำนัก
เรียนเย้
สวัสดีปีใหม่ปีใหม่ปีใหม่เย่สวัสดีปีใหม่
ครับไปค่ะครับเดี๋ยววันนี้เราเปิดเจอกัน
th ดีกับนักเรียนในช่องคอม PM สเบอร์ไทย
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันปีใหม่ใช่ไหมครับวัน
ปีใหม่วันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันเสาร์วันนี้วันเสาร์นะครับวัน
เสาร์อย่าตีปากกาฮาวันเสาร์นี่วันนี้วัน
เสาร์วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันที่ 1
ใช่แล้ววันเสาร์วันที่ 1 อ่ะวันที่ 1
เป็นวันปีใหม่วันปีใหม่เป็นวันที่ 1 ของ
เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนมกราคมค่ะดีๆวันปีใหม่ต้องเดือน
มกราคมวันที่ 1 มกราคมเท่านั้นเนอะวันที่
1 มกราคมเป็นวันปีใหม่นะครับ a แล้ว
เดือนหนึ่ง
ใช่ครับวันที่ 1 เดือน 1
มกราคมเป็นวันปีใหม่อ่ะแล้วปีใหม่ปีนี้ปี
ใหม่ปีนิดปีพตอะไรครับ
ปีนี้ปีคศ
2000  22 ค่ะใช่ครับปีคศ 2010  22
day  22 เรียกว่าเรียกว่าปีใหม่เออได้
ครับปีใหม่
แล้วปีกปีเก่าก็คือปีที่แล้วฉันใช่ครับ
ถ้าเป็นปีเก่าปีที่แล้วนี่ปีนี้ปีนี้ปี
นี้ปี
2022 ปีนี้แต่ปีนี้ปีใหม่งานส่วนปี
2021 เป็นปีที่แล้วปีที่แล้วได้ครับปี
ที่แล้ว
ปีเก่ามีเก่าใช่ครับปีที่แล้ว
เองแล้วปีนี้ปีนี้ปี 2022 แล้วปีต่อไป
ครับปีหน้าปีหน้าปี
หน้าเป็นปี
[เพลง]
2000  23  23 ใช่ครับปี
2023 นะครับขอแค่อ้าแล้วอิๆ
วันนี้วันนี้ที่เรามาเรียนกันวันนี้กี่
โมงแล้วครับกี่โมงแล้ว
[เพลง]
เรียมดูนาฬิกา
ครับตอนนี้
8:00 น 45 นขอเบอร์ 8 โมง 45 นาทีน
8 โมง 45 นาทีเป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมครับตอน
เช้าเขาเช้าๆยังเช้าอยู่แล้ว
ปกติครับเมื่อคืนเครียดอี้ได้ปาร์ตี้
เนี่ยอ๋อเมื่อคืนมีปาร์ตี้ไหมพี่ติ๊กไม่
มีปาร์ตี้เป็นพี่ไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวรอบรอบ
กรุงเทพฯจะมีไฟไปเหอะไฟปีใหม่เยอะเลยใช่
ครับมีงานปีใหม่ใช่ครับเครียดพี่
ไปดูไฟไหนครับไปดูไฟล์
หมอไปที่เป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะคิดจริงๆเฮ้อ
ใช่ครับใช่ครับหน้ามีไฟประดับเยอะเลยตาม
ถนนเยอะเลยให้หา fatigue จะขับรถไปตามถนน
ก็จะมีไฟปีใหม่ปีใหม่เพชรจะมีนักเรียนพี่
พยายามว่ามีมีใหม่อ่ะมีไฟปีใหม่
หาก็มีไฟ Fire  Fire เหมือนไหมเหมือนไม่
เป็นไฟปีใหม่อ่ะสวยงามเยอะแยะไปหมดเลยพี่
ก็ขับรถแล้วก็ดูนูโวตรงนี้สู่หวยตรงนี้
หนูไปช้าใช่ใช่ครับ
นี้
ก็
8:00 นเช้า 15 แล้ว
8:45 แล้วเป็นตอนเช้าของวันปีใหม่ 5 วัน
ปีใหม่วันปีใหม่เราทำอะไรกันบ้างครับใน
วันปีใหม่คนไทยคนไทยทำอะไรกัน
คนไทยจะ
ไปวัดใช้ครับเราไปวัดเราพากันไปวัดใจครับ
หน่ะไปวัดไปไหว้ไหว้พระ
ไปไหว้พระไปทำบุญทำบุญนะครับทำบุญใส่บาตร
นี่ใส่บาตรพระแบบนี้นะครับเนอะใส่บาตรใช่
ครับของใส่บาตรใจครับเอาของใส่บาตรเอา
ข้าวเอาข้าวใส่บาตรเอาอาหาร
อาหารแล้วก็บางทีก็จะมีของใช้มีอาของใช้
ให้พระอ่ามียานะครับมียายเม็ดเวลาให้ครับ
บาท
จ่ายๆมียางนิด 5 เป็นยาเป็นยาอ่ะใส่ก็ใส่
บาตรนะครับน่าใช้ครับในวันปีใหม่เราก็จะ
พากันพาหาลูกภาพพ่อพาแม่พาทุกๆคนที่อยู่
บ้านเดี่ยวบ้านเดียวกับเรานะครับไปวัด
เนอะไปวัดกันมากแต่กลับไปทำบุญที่วัดหือ
มาแล้วดีจังตอนเช้าเราก็จะไปวัดกันแล้วก็
หลังจากที่ไปวัดแล้วเราก็จะจะคากันพาการ
ไปกินข้าวด้วยกัน
ก็ได้ครับไปกินข้าวด้วยกันอาจจะบางคนไป
กินที่ร้านอาหารได้นะครับบางคนก็มากิน
ข้าวด้วยกันที่บ้าน
หอไอ้ก็เครียดที่ล่ะคะไปกินข้าวที่ร้าน
อาหารในเนื้อหาใช่ครับพี่อาร์ตี้ก็จะไป
กินข้าวที่ร้านอาหารแล้วก็เพื่อที่ก็จะ
กลับบ้านเพื่อตีที่
ไปเจอกับอ่าข้อกับแม่ของพี่อาร์ตี้บ้าน
พี่อาร์ตี้อยู่ต่างจังหวัด
ห้องน่าได้ครับในวันปีใหม่ในวันปีใหม่ขอ
คนไทยก็จะกลับบ้านไปหาพ่อหาแม่ที่ต่าง
จังหวัด
ได้ครับบ้านบ้านของพี่อาร์ตี้
หาค่ะที่ไหนคะเออบ้านของพี่อาร์ตี้อยู่
ที่จังหวัดประจวบครับเออเดี๋ยวนะพี่วาด
แผนที่ประเทศไทยโอเคเหมือนไหมเอาใหม่เอา
ใหม่เอามาให้ไม่เหมือนไม่ให้เหมือนพี่
ต้าร์ว่าให้ให้เหมือนๆหน่อยพี่เป็นคนไทย
ก็ต้องบ้านที่นี่ประเทศไทย
โอเคตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ก็ยังไม่เหมือนด้วยหน่อย
ตอนนี้อยู่ที่ได้อยู่ตรงนี้อยู่ใกล้ตรง
ไหนอ่ะเทพประจวบอยู่ตรงนี้
ประจวบคีรีขันธ์อาเพียวพี่ก็ขับรถกลับ
บ้านกลับบ้านที่ประจวบคีรีขันธ์ 5 ขับรถ
ไปนะครับอ่าวันปีใหม่วันปีใหม่กลับบ้านไป
แล้วไปกินข้าวกินข้าวกับพ่อกับแม่นะครับๆ
ที่อ่าที่บ้านที่ประจุชายครับ
อ่ะฮ่าๆ
ไอหน้าโอเคอาย
พูดเยอะใช่ไหมพูดเยอะไม่เกี่ยวอ่ะโอเค
ก็อ่า
ก็กลับไปนะครับเบี้ยที่อะไรนะครับผมบ้าน
ของเดียมอ๋อใช่ครับ
มหาสารคามอ๋อบ้านของเรียมอยู่มหาสารคาม
มหาสารคามอยู่ตรงนี้
ถ้าอยู่ไกลตัดกรุงเทพฯแต่น้องเรียมโรง
เรียนกลับบ้านไหม
น้องเขียวไม่ได้กลับบ้านอยู่อยู่แล้วแล้ว
เรียนอยู่ที่นี่ที่อยู่แล้วอ๋อ ok  ok
อ่ะในประเทศไทยมีคนไทยหลายคนหลายคนไม่ได้
อยู่ที่บ้าน
ใช่ครับคนไทยคนอื่นไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านก็จะ
กลับบ้านวันปีใหม่บางคนอยู่เชียงใหม่
วันปีใหม่ก็กลับบ้านกลับเชียงใหม่
นะครับหลับบ้านได้ๆครับแชร์ครับเธอแต่
น้องเรียว 5 กลับบ้านได้พี่ก็กลับบ้านที่
ประจวบฯหน้าวันปีใหม่ไร้ครับเออ
ไม่กลับบ้านโรงเรียนทุกวันอยู่
บ้านอยู่แล้วอ่ะไม่ต้องกลับบ้านก็โอเคถ้า
อ้าวันปีใหม่ถ้าไม่ได้กลับบ้านก็จะไป
เที่ยวไปเที่ยวที่อื่นชนะไปเที่ยวเออไป
เที่ยว
รถไปเที่ยวถ่ายรูป
สวยงามในวันปีใหม่นะครับ
เราทำอะไรอีกค่ะที่เออเออวันปีใหม่
นอกจากอับบ้านไปกินข้าวไปกินกินข้าวกับ
ครอบครัวนะครับมีบางคนบางคนที่ปรับไม่ได้
กลับบ้านไม่ได้ใช่ครับท่านไม่ได้ 5 ไม่
ได้กลับนะครับไม่ได้กลับต้องอาจจะต้องทำ
งานต้องทำงานทำงานได้ครับอ้าอย่างนี้นี่
แบบนี้นี่คนนี้พี่สาวคนนี้กลับบ้านไม่ได้
กลับบ้านไม่ได้เฮ้อคนอื่นที่กลับมาแล้ว
อ้ะพี่อาร์ตี้ที่กลับมาแล้วก็ต้อง
โทรศัพท์หาแล้วก็วีดีโอวีดีโอคุยกันคุย
กันไส้ทำ
คุยกันได้ครับ Video  Call คุยกันนะครับ
ในคนสำหรับคนที่กลับบ้านไม่ได้เอ้อโอเค
โอเคนะครับ
แล้วก็ห้า
กินข้าวใช่ครับเรากินให้เข้ากันพร้อมกับ
ครอบครัว
นายครับหลายๆคนมีคุณออกคุณแม่ก็จะเป็นอ่า
มีคุณแม่ก็จะเป็นคุณยายคุณยายของหลานอะมี
หลานชายมีหลานสาวอ่ามีอาบภรรยามีแม่มีพ่อ
หลายๆคนนะวันปีใหม่หลายๆคนก็จะมาเจอกัน
เจอกันหลายๆคนอาจในวันปีใหม่นะครับเนี่ย
ทุกคนก็จะมีความสุขนะได้พูดได้โต้วีการ
ใช้ครับ
ในวันปีใหม่นะครับโอเค
เออแล้วเวลาที่เรากินข้าวกับครอบครัวกิน
ข้าวกับครอบครัวเสร็จแล้วเราก็จะพา
ครอบครัว
ถ้าครอบครัวทุกๆคน
หน้าตาคุณยายพาหลานนะครับอ่าพาพ่อพาแม่พา
กันไปวัดอีก 5 ไปวัดใช่ครับไปทำอะไรค่ะ
พี่หาไฟวัดไปไหว้พระทำบุญนะครับๆ
ครับไทยเรียมเป็นคนไทย
เป็นคนเห็นคนไทยในครับคนไทย
ไปวัดไหว้พระให้ครับ
9 วัด 9 วัดห้าใช่ครับบางคนไปทำบุญ 9
วัน 9 วันหน้าในวันปีใหม่ใช้ครับทำยังไง
คะเออ 9 วัด
เราก็พากันนะครับพากันขับรถที่รูป
หายโอเคมาแล้วมีเฮวัดไปไหว้พระ 9 วัดขับ
รถไปวัดที่ 1 ขับรถไปวัดที่หนึ่งอ้ะก็
เข้าไปไหว้พระเอาเอา
พวงมาลัยไปไหว้พระนะครับมีวัดที่ 1 นะคะ
ใช่ครับเมื่อวัดที่ 1 เฮียดีขับรถไปใช่
ครับขับรถไป
คูแล้วก็มีอ่าธูปใช่ไหมคะผู้มาใช่ครับมี
ธูป
วิธีเรียนมีพวงมาลัยพวงมาลัยอยู่ที่ว่า
ตรงมาลัย
แล้วก็มีเพียรใช่ครับมีเขียน
มีดอกบัว
ดอกบัว
อีดอกบัว
แล้วก็ว่ายใช่ครับไหว้พระ
ที่มีสวดมนต์ไหมคะมีสวดมนต์หน่อยสวดมนต์
นิดหน่อยได้ครับนะโมตัสสะภะคะวะโต
อะระหะโตสัมมาสัมพุทธัสสะอะสวดมนต์ชัยเขา
ไหว้พระสวดมนต์ให้เราให้เราโคกมีให้เรา
โชคดี
ให้เรามีความสุขมีความสุขในวันปีใหม่ทราย
ทั้ง
แล้ววัดที่ 1 เราไปวัดที่ 1 แล้วได้ครับ
พี่ก็ขับรถจะไปอีกไปอีกไปอีกวัดที่ 2 ขับ
รถไปสองต่อสองใส่ครับ
ก็ไปไหว้เหมือนกันไปว่าอีกเหมือนกันใช่
ครับเออเออ
ก็มีพวงมาลัยไหว้หน้าแล้วก็มีทำบุญใช่
ครับ
แล้วก็มีบางทีก็มีบริจาคเงินด้วยบริจาค
เงินบริจาคเงินให้ที่วัดใช้ครับเราจะเห็น
ที่มาเห็นต้าตู้บริจาคอ่ะตู้รับบริจาคใช่
ครับ
เราก็ใช้เงินใช่ไหมคะหน้าใส่เงินลงไปเอา
เงินใส่เงินลงไปอ่านลงไปในตู้บริจาคใช้
ครับแล้วก็
สาธุแสนขำ
[เพลง]
แล้วเที่ยวขับรถขับรถไปอีกไปวัดที่ 2 วัด
ที่ 3 วัดที่ 4 วัดที่ 5 ไปเรื่อยๆใช่
ครับ
โอ้ต้องถึงวัดที่
1 นายครับจนถึงวัดที่ 9
วู
8  9
วูวัดเจ้า 5 ใช้ครับกาววัดหน้าทั้งหมด
ทั้งหมดทั้งหมดเรียกไหว้พระ 9 วัด
ใจครับ
เครียดที่ขับรถอยู่นานไหมคะเออขับรถอาไม่
นานไม่นานเพราะว่ามีวัดหลายๆวัดอยู่ใกล้ๆ
กันถูกด้วยใกล้กันได้ครับน้าดีค่ะได้ครับ
เออแล้วก็
ไหว้พระ 9 วัดเสร็จแล้วก็กลับบ้านทุกคนก็
กลับบ้านอ่ะมาเราพูดคุยกันเพราะว่าไม่ได้
เจอกันนาน
แต่น้าใช่ครับปีใหม่หนึ่งครั้งกลับบ้านไป
หนึ่งครั้งนะเจอกันก็คุยกันพูดกันใจครับ
เราก็กินข้าวกันๆกินข้าวด้วยกันนะในวันปี
ใหม่
ไปไหว้พระ 9 วัดมาได้ใช่ครับบ้านมากิน
ข้าว
คุยกันใช้กับห้อแล้วก็มีมีวันปีใหม่เราก็
จะให้ของขวัญด้วยเราก็จะให้ของขวัญให้ของ
ขวัญเพื่อนๆให้ของขวัญคุณพ่อคุณแม่อ่าให้
ของขวัญ
ทุกๆคนใช่ครับเราจะให้ของขวัญกันอ้าในวัน
ปีใหม่ไปครับอ่าได้ใช่ครับก็คือของขวัญ
อ่ะนะครับของขวัญวันปีใหม่เราให้ของขวัญ
หาร้านได้รับได้รับของขวัญเป็นอะไรคะ 5
เพียงตีก็จะได้รับของขวัญเป็นขนม
ขนมเป็นของกินของกินเป็นขนม
ของเรียมก็มีคุกกี้อ้าเป็นขนมแบบนี้อัน
ไหนๆนี่ขนมนะครับเป็นคุกกี้ครับใช่ค่ะ
เรียนก็ได้รับของขวัญก็ใช่ครับพี่ชายขับ
เป็นเรียกเราเรียกว่าของขวัญปีใหม่
ปีใหม่ใครเขารับของขวัญปีใหม่มหาชัยให้
ให้ของขวัญปีใหม่ใช่ใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
เตรียมให้ของขวัญปีใหม่เพียงดีเปียตีก็จะ
รับของขวัญปีใหม่เอ่อเออใช้ครับเดี๋ยวเรา
ก็จะพูดว่า
สุขสันต์วันปีใหม่ได้เราก็จะพูดว่าสุข
สันต์วันปีใหม่นะครับโอเคแล้วก็อ้าปีใหม่
นี้วันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้ก็
พูดกับนักเรียนเหมือนกันพูดว่าสุขสันต์
วันปีใหม่ด้วยเหมือนกันไหมครับ
โอเคแล้วก็วันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วเวลาหมดแล้ว
พี่ก็ต้องพูดพูดอีกว่าสวัสดีปีใหม่อ่ะใจ
ครับ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ครับอ่าขอให้น้องเรียนมขอให้
นักเรียนทุกคนมีความสุขนะสุขสันต์วันปี
ใหม่อ่า
ขอให้พี่อาร์ตี้มีความสุขมากๆ
โอเคขอบคุณหน้านักมากจ้าได้ให้นักเรียนก็
มีความสุขไหมคะ 555 สวัสดีปีใหม่ครับบ๊าย
บายน
[เพลง]